wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
haben auf unserer erde eine künstliche
sonne geschaffen 100.000 grad ist sie
heiß und steht in den usa
was haben sie damit herausgefunden und
können sie uns damit vielleicht vor
gefährlichen sonnenstürmen schützen
klicks um science-fiction heute mit
jakob von breaking lab abonniert
brainlab nur dann verpasst sie auch dort
keines der coolen videos herzlich
willkommen heute also mit jakob von
breaking lab dort gibt es übrigens
aktuell ein hammer video zum thema so
sieht ein schwarzes loch von innen aus
unbedingt angucken der link ist in der
video schreibung und kommt noch mal am
ende des videos also los gehts bitte
jakob ohne die sonne kein leben kein
wunder also dass die wissenschaft
lebenswerk sterne auf den grund geht die
sonne ist etwa 100 mal größer als die
erde rund 150 millionen kilometer von
uns entfernt und an der oberfläche zirka
5500 grad heiß also nicht die
einfachsten bedingungen und die sonne zu
erforschen aber genau das wollen
wissenschaftler der university of
wisconsin-madison jetzt machen dafür
haben sie ein unglaublich komplexes
konstrukt entwickelt um vorgänge rund um
die sonne besser nachzuvollziehen
konkret geht es darum wie das
magnetische feld der sonne unser
gesamtes sonnensystem beeinflusst die
sonne ist bereits seit etwa 4,5
milliarden jahren das zentrum unseres
sonnensystems und hat uns so das leben
ermöglicht dabei setzt sie unglaublich
viel energie frei hier ein beispiel das
auch ziemlich gut erklärt warum mir die
sonne sogar auf der erde so gut als
energiequelle nutzen können obwohl sie
fast 150 millionen kilometer von uns
entfernt ist in einer sekunde setzt die
sonne mehr energie frei
als alle kernkraftwerke der erde in
750.000 jahren also bei dem projekt der
uni visconti madison geht es ja um das
magnetische feld der sonne und wie
dieses das sonnensystem beeinflusst wie
die erde besitzt nämlich auch die sonne
ein magnetfeld das bis zu fünf mal
stärker als das irdische sein kann
die magnetischen prozesse verursachen
unter anderem die sogenannten
sonnenflecken und viele weitere
phänomene für eine komplette rotation
benötigt die sonne rund einen monat
diese rotation lässt das magnetfeld in
form einer rotierenden spirale entstehen
rund um den bereich des sonnen
dieses entstandene magnetfeld sich alle
elf jahre um das wird
sonnenfleckenzyklus genannt bei der
arbeit mit dem big red bull punkten die
wissenschaftler heliumgas hinein und
wandeln ist in plasma um da die sonne
ein riesiger stern aus plasma ist ist
das ein elementarer schritt um die echte
sonne möglichst originalgetreu zu
imitieren
natürlich gibt es auch das magnetfeld
und das sind überraschenderweise einfach
durch einen magneten im zentrum der
installation simuliert zu guter letzt
lassen die wissenschaftler strom durch
die mini sonne laufen und können dann
beobachten die plasma und magnetfeld
sich gegenseitig beeinflussen ließen
peterson der verantwortliche
wissenschaftler setzt der installation
aber auch klare grenzen indem er
folgendes sagt wir können die sonne
nicht komplett nach bauen das ist
unmöglich aber und das ist der
wesentliche vorteil des balls mit dem
gerät könne man wesentliche
physikalische vorgänge besser verstehen
die rund um die sonne geschehen
insbesondere ging es darum wie der solar
wind entsteht denn darüber herrscht
totale uneinigkeit der solar wind
besteht aus geladenen teilchen diese
unglaublich heiß sind dass sie sich von
der gravitation der sonne lösen und
wegfliegen mit einer geschwindigkeit von
400 bis 800 km h fliegt das dann ins all
und ja man kann sich vorstellen dass das
würde die erde ziemlich gefährlich
werden kann
die sonne verliert dadurch pro sekunde
etwa eine millionen tonnen an material
was aber im vergleich zur gesamtmasse
der sonne relativ wenig ist und in
unserem sonnensystem gibt es planeten
die davon direkt getroffen werden der
merkur ist ein beispiel dafür
er besitzt nur ein schwaches magnetfeld
und keine atmosphäre deshalb ist der
merkur ziemlich ungeschützt wird
getroffen und ist aus diesem grund
allein schon lebensfeindlich extrem
lebensfeindlich um genau zu sein deshalb
ist das magnetfeld der erde für uns eine
ziemlich coole sache weil das fliegende
teilchen aus dem all
zusammen mit der atmosphäre ab werden
kann der weg dieser heißen fliegenden
teilchen richtung erde soll auch am big
red bull untersucht werden
die forscher konnten sogar die
sogenannte parker spirale nachahmen die
nach dem berühmten solar astrophysiker
eugene parker benannt ist die bagger
spirale ist die natürlich vorkommende
spirale die das magnetfeld der sonne
formt und die sonne ist so stark dass
die packer spirale das gesamte
sonnensystem berührt peterson sagt dazu
satellitenmessungen stimmt
nicht genau mit dem parker spirale
modell überein jedoch nur zu einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt so dass wir niemals
in der lage sein werden eine simultane
großformatige karte davon zu erstellen
wie wir es im labor könnten die
experimentellen messungen konnten nun
die theorie bestätigen aber es gibt noch
eine menge was wir nicht wissen zum
beispiel wie sonnenwinde der schwerkraft
der sonne entkommen oder wie wir sie
genauer vorhersagen können wie
gefährlich können solche sonnenwinde
oder im extremfall sonnenstürme denn für
uns werden wenn sie auf die erde zu
lassen also der größte teil der wolke
wird im abstand von etwa zehn ehrt
radien durch das magnetfeld der erde
abgelenkt und um das von diesem feld
beherrschte gebiet der magnetosphäre
herumgeführt
jedoch kann die magnetosphäre unter dem
druck eines besonders starken
sonnenstürmen verformt werden die folge
sind elektrische ströme die bis in die
ionosphäre etwa hundert kilometer über
der erdoberfläche eindringt und die
werden begleitet von polarlicht denn die
aufgrund der deformation der
magnetosphäre bis in unsere breiten
sichtbar sind die schwankungen dieser
ströme induzieren aber auch überspannung
in großflächigen elektrischen
leitungsnetzen die dann auch zum ausfall
des netzes führen können wie zum
beispiel am 30
oktober 2003 damals fiel aufgrund der
hohen magnetischen aktivität im
schwedischen malmö für 20 bis 50 minuten
das stromnetz aus netzausfälle sind aber
nicht alles was dann droht zusammen mit
den gaswolken werden bei den stärksten
sonnenstürmen auch sehr energiereiche
teilchen von der sonne ausgestoßen die
können erst satelliten durchschlagen und
durch ihre ionisierende wirkung die
elektronik der satelliten lahmlegen in
der ionosphäre erhöhen sie die
elektrische ladung dichte die dann die
funkwellen ausbreitung beeinträchtigt so
können gps geräte während eines
sonnensturms durch die laufzeit
verzögerung der gps signale fehlerhafte
position anzeigen vor allem aber
gefährden die energiereichen teilchen
die besatzung der iss sie dann
kurzzeitig einer sehr sehr hohen
strahlendosis ausgesetzt sind
die belastung an der erdoberfläche ist
gering da die meisten zeichen in der
erdatmosphäre stecken bleiben aber
menschen die fliegen können getroffen
werden passagierflugzeuge haben ja so
eine höhe von ungefähr 10.000 metern und
da ist 80 prozent der atmosphäre unter
den und während solcher ereignisse
kann es dazu kommen dass sie deutlich
stärker gefährdet sind es ist also auch
von großen gesellschaftlichen interesse
mit den big red bull mehr über solche
sonnenstürme zu erfahren dass juwi
meldeten team untersucht auch die
sogenannten works also das rübchen des
sonnenplasmas dass die nasa
wissenschaftler mit blogs in einer
lavalampe vergleichen und diese rückte
der sonne sind mehrere hundert male so
groß wie die erde
die so röther werden zwar von satelliten
beobachtet aber niemand weiß wieso ist
sie gibt und was sie bewirken mit der
mini sonne könnten die forscher sehr
ähnliche rückzieher sehen und nun
verfolgen wie sie sich entwickeln ich
finde das extrem gespannt was da gerade
passiert und ich glaube persönlich dass
die forschung an der sonne eigentlich
gerade wirklich erst begonnen hat und
auch über schwarze löcher gibt es immer
wieder neue bahnbrechende erkenntnisse
so sieht ein schwarzes loch von hinaus
das ist das aktuelle video vom breaking
lebt anklicken hier anschauen und auf
jeden fall anklicken und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran